Fully turbulent steady flow of 250
cubic feet per second passes through a
1,000 ft long 6 ft diameter pipe with an
F1 of 0.012
and then through a 250 ft long 4.5
diameter pipe. If the friction head loss
in pipe 2 is 3 ft greater
than that in pipe 1 where h2 equals h1 +
3 ft. Determine the Darcy Weisbach
friction factor F2 for the second pipe
and neglect minor losses.
So this problem is very direct in that
it tells you that it's looking for the
Darcy Wiseback friction factor F2 for
the second pipe. So, searching for that
in the reference manual will lead us to
section 6.3.2
where we can write out the equation. But
first, in case you need a visual, this
is basically what the pipe structure
looks like according to the problem.
So if we write out our known we can see
that
Q = 250 cubic feet/s
D1 = 6 ft. L1 = 1,000 ft and F1 is
0.012.
These are all for pipe 1. For pipe 2, D2
= 4.5 ft, L2 = 250 ft. and we are
solving for f_sub_2 in this problem. So
let's write out the Darcy Wiseback
equation and see what we've got so far.
This equation is going to be hf =
f_sub_1 * l1 / d1
* v1^ 2 / 2g equals f_sub_2 = l2 / d2
v2^2 / 2g.
Now most of our values have been given
already but what we can see
is that we are missing velocity
for both pipe one and pipe two right
now. However, we do have what we need to
solve for those. So let's do that first.
So velocity is going to be given
by Q= VA.
So if we have our A's, we don't have our
areas yet, but we can calculate those in
turn from our diameters.
So A1 =<unk> D ^2 over 4, which will
be<unk> 6T^2 / 4
= 28.26 26 square ft.
Area 2 will be<unk> * 4.5^ 2 / 4 will
give us
15.9.
So now that we have our areas, let's
solve for V1. If v1 equals q / a1, then
that's going to be 250 cubic feet/s
over 28.26
square ft. And this will come out to
8.84
ft/s.
Likewise, velocity 2 is going to be
equal to q over a2. The q is the same
since it's constant through both pipes.
And this will come out to about 15.92
ft pers.
So now that we have everything we need
for the Darcy Weisbach equation, let's
narrow down exactly what H2 and H1 are
equal to.
So if we start by solving for just h1,
we can write out just half of the
equation stating that h1 equals f_sub_1
* l1 / d1 * v1^2 / 2g.
Plugging in all of these terms, we can
see that f_sub_1 is going to be 0.012,
012. L1 is 1,000 ft. D1 is 6 ft. V2 is
our recently calculated 8.84 ft/s
squared. And then 2 * gravity of 32.2
ft/s squared.
Solving this out, we get an h1 of 2.43
ft.
Likewise, this will mean that h2 is
going to be 2.43 43 + 3 giving us 5.43
ft.
So now we have everything we need
to solve for the F2 value in the Darcy
Wisebach friction factor equation.
So in the same way that we recently
solved for H1, we can now set H2 as our
known and back calculate for the missing
F2 value.
So plugging in our terms, we have 5.43t
43t
equ= F_sub_2
* 250 ft over 4.5 ft
time
oh actually 15.7
feet per
over 2 * 32.2 ft pers squared.
And if we rearrange the unknowns and
known here, we can isolate f_sub_2 and
find that it is equal to 0.025, 025,
which is our third answer on the left.
So, this problem can be confusing just
because there's a few steps you have to
solve for before you get the value
you're actually being asked to find.
So again, we start by finding our
velocities because those are terms that
are missing from the Darcy Weisbach
equation.
Then we use that
to find our H1 and then subsequently our
H2 values. And from there we can use all
of that to find our F2 value. And that's
it.